today's video is going to tell you how
to get more villagers in
animal crossing new horizons but more
importantly how you can actually have a
say
in which villagers they are people of
the internet retroreconciler here and
we're back with another animal crossing
new horizons video
today is all about villager recruitment
and we're getting started right now so
maybe you're new to the animal crossing
series or you're early in the game and
find yourself wondering how you turn
your quiet island into a busy town with
multiple villagers
and even if you aren't new to the series
things are a little bit different for
new horizons than previous animal
crossing games
the changes are definitely for the
better though as now you'll actually
have a role to play in which specific
villagers move to your island
if you want to that is in previous
animal crossing games the villager
move-in process was purely
random having as many villagers as
possible is also a great way to improve
your island's star ranking
now go ahead and leave me a comment down
below and let me know which villager
you'd love to have
on your island so how are things
different with new horizons as opposed
to
previous animal crossing games to start
you'll have two villagers randomly
assigned to your island when you first
start the game from here on out though
you can actually recruit new villagers
to move to your island
don't get in too big of a rush if you're
just starting out in order to recruit
villagers you'll want to progress
naturally through the game by checking
in with tom nook frequently to see what
you can do next
sometime after you've built nook's
granny nook will ask you to build and
help furnish houses for new villagers
you get to decide where these houses
will go and you can put them anywhere on
your map but you may want to start
thinking about how you want to organize
your neighborhoods
and if you want to have any themed areas
you'll place the furniture outside and
near the house don't worry about this
one too much as you can easily remove
the furniture later on
houses can be moved later on as well but
it'll cost you and take a full day of
in-game time
to make it happen now here's where you
have a decision to make if you just want
the villagers and don't really care
about who they
are then go ahead and place the plot of
land place your furniture and check in
with nook once again
at this point you'll notice a sold sign
on the plot of land and you should be
able to see the name of the incoming
villager
you can do this two more times for a
total of three new villagers which will
give you
five total on your island for now but
if you'd like to have a say on who moves
to your island instead of letting fate
decide
you'll need some nook miles tickets you
can purchase these from the kiosk
at resident services you'll also need to
do this before you place a new
housing plot once you get your hands on
some nook miles tickets head on over to
your airport and tell orville you'd like
to visit an island using a nook miles
ticket
once you arrive at that island look
around and you should eventually spot a
villager
feel free to talk to them and decide if
it's someone you'd like to have on your
island
if you want them to move in keep talking
to them until you hit a point in the
conversation where they ask
about moving to your island once you
convince them to move then you're ready
to head back to your own island and
prepare their housing plot
again you can do this until you have a
total of five villagers
on your island once you have five
villagers though things will change
slightly you'll need to talk to nook and
choose the
let's talk infrastructure dialogue
option from there you can get new
housing plots for 10
000 bells and by the way you can have a
total of 10 villagers on your island and
that does not
include human players as a general rule
of thumb you'll still want to make sure
you don't place the housing plots
until you've found a villager who wants
to move in of course if you're fine with
it being a random villager then you can
place the housing plots at any time now
of course you can keep visiting islands
and recruiting villagers that way if you
want but that's not the only way
to get villagers after you upgrade
resident services from a tent to a
physical building
you'll now have another method of
recruiting villagers
your campsite nook will ask you to place
the campsite after you've upgraded
resident services
the first day after you place that
campsite you'll have a villager
show up there now kind of bad news here
this villager is guaranteed to move to
your island no matter
what you do what you say to him that
first camper will always move to your
island
now after that first campsite villager
you will continue to get visitors
at that campsite the day will be random
but isabel will always announce when you
have a camper as soon as you fire up
your game for the first time now
these villagers are not guaranteed to
move into your island you actually have
a say in it
if you talk to a camper and they seem
like a villager you'd like to have moved
to your island
keep talking to them until you have a
chance to recruit them to your island
usually the campers will have you play a
little game or do an errand before
they'll actually agree to move in
now another thing when you upgrade
resident services nook will also mention
the ability to scan
animal crossing amiibo cards to recruit
villagers
unfortunately these amiibo cards were
actually made back in 2016 and are now
out of print of course you can find used
ones online but usually the prices
aren't so great especially for the more
popular villagers
i've heard of some folks having good
luck buying these on etsy but again just
make sure you're careful here and that
the cards are in fact legitimate and of
course that you're not paying some
astronomical price
if you do happen to come across some
amiibo cards you can find that option at
the nook stop in
resident services you'll want to choose
invite amiibo camper from the menu
scan your amiibo card and then select
yes to continue
the character will appear on screen and
now you can invite them to stay
at your campsite if you don't have
anyone currently visiting your campsite
the amiibo villager will appear
immediately now don't worry if you do
already have a camper there because then
the amiibo camper will just show up the
next
day from here check in with them at the
campsite just like you would any other
camper
with this villager though you'll likely
be asked to complete a series of tasks
using diy recipes to craft certain items
for them the good news is if you don't
have the diy recipe they'll give you the
recipe for free
with an amiibo campsite visitor though
you likely won't be able to convince
them to stay
after just one visit unlike the regular
visitors it may take repeat visits for
them to agree your persistence will
eventually pay off though and they'll
decide to move in
when they do check in with once again
about your island's infrastructure and
get
a new plot of land ready to go believe
it or not there's actually one
more way to recruit villagers to your
island although this one requires
coordination with
another human player you see anytime a
villager plans to move
away from an island they'll take a full
day
to pack up if you can work it out with a
friend to visit their island while one
of their villagers is in this position
you'll have the option of talking to the
on the move villager and recruit them to
your island instead
whew that's a lot and while some of this
is certainly tedious it's nice to know
nintendo is giving us more options than
before
when it comes to picking our villagers
again even if it is a bit tedious
don't forget you have a maximum of 10
villager slots and you can also use the
nook miles island method at any point
when you are under
10 villagers now if you found something
valuable in this video hit that like
button and if you want to see more
animal crossing videos like this go
ahead and subscribe and don't forget to
ring
the bell that's gonna be it for today's
video thank you so much for watching